i is
all right got a two minute warning
okay
yes
yes
okay
the limbo
[Music]
hi everyone hello
happy monday uh today we are joined by
homeland security advisor and deputy
national security advisor
dr liz sherwood randall and deputy
national security advisor
for cyber and emerging technologies and
neuberger
i know you all know who they are so i'm
going to skip the introduction so we
have
more time for questions we have very
limited time but we'll try to take as
many as possible so with that i'll turn
it over to liz
it's great to be with you today thank
you jen
i have an update for you on the colonial
pipeline and what the biden
administration
is doing to provide assistance through a
whole of government
effort on friday evening may 7 colonial
pipeline reported that its pipeline
system had been subject to a ransomware
cyber attack
colonial chose to shut down its pipeline
operations as a precautionary measure
and to ensure that the ransomware could
not migrate from business computer
systems to those that control
and operate the pipeline we've been in
ongoing contact with colonial
and the president continues to be
regularly briefed on the incident
and our work colonial is currently
working with its private cyber security
consultants to assess potential damage
and to determine
when it is safe to bring the pipeline
back online
thus far colonial has told us that it
has not suffered
damage and can be brought back online
relatively quickly
but that safety is a priority given that
it has never before
taken the entire pipeline down beginning
on friday night soon after we learned of
the shutdown the white house convened an
interagency team
that included the department of energy
which is the lead agency for incident
response in this case
the department of homeland security's
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency or cisa
the fbi the department of transportation
pipeline safety and hazardous materials
safety administration
the department of the treasury the
department of defense and other agencies
to give you a sense of what we've been
doing together since that first meeting
we have met
throughout the weekend the department of
energy's information
energy information agency or eia is in
contact with state and local agencies
to assess current supply and impacts due
to the shutdown
doe has also convened the oil and
natural gas and electric
sector utility partners to share details
about the ransomware attack
and discuss recommended measures to
mitigate further incidents across the
industry
dhs's sysa is preparing a release to go
to the broader critical infrastructure
community
to ensure it has visibility into the
ransomware attack
and it's taking appropriate measures to
protect its networks
colonial is responsible for safely
returning the pipeline to service
and our role in the federal government
is to take proactive steps
to analyze the impacts of the shutdown
on the delivery of gasoline
diesel and aviation fuel in states that
are dependent on the pipeline
and to identify federal options for
alleviating supply shortfalls
should they develop for example
to help address potential supply
disruptions the department of
transportation
issued an hours of service waiver
yesterday
which provides greater flexibility to
drivers transporting gasoline diesel
jet fuel and other refined petroleum
products across 17 states
as well as the district of columbia
right now there is not a supply shortage
we are preparing for multiple possible
contingencies because that's our job
especially on the homeland security team
and considering
what additional steps may be useful to
mitigate any potential disruptions to
supply
this weekend's events put the spotlight
on the fact that our nation's critical
infrastructure is largely owned and
operated by private sector companies
when those companies are attacked they
serve as the first line of defense
and we depend on the effectiveness of
their defenses
to improve the cyber security of our
critical infrastructure the biden
administration has already launched a
high priority
initiative to collaborate with our
private sector partners
to harden our defenses and to build our
nation's resilience
and that is a perfect segue to my
colleague ann newberger our deputy
national security advisor for cyber and
emerging technologies
thanks
thank you liz good morning everyone so
building on liz's comments
as you know on friday colonial shut
proactively its pipeline operations
as a precautionary measure to ensure
ransomware would not spread to its
sensitive operational
networks in response we're taking a
multi-pronged and whole of government
response
to this incident and to ransomware
overall
first we're actively engaged with the
company and offered support as needed to
restore their systems
right now they've not asked for cyber
support for the federal government
but we remain available to meet their
cybersecurity
needs second we're aggressively
investigating the incident
and its culprits as part of their work
today
fbi released a flash alert with
indicators of compromise and mitigation
measures
once infected the fbi identified the
ransomware
as the dark side variant which they've
been investigating since
october of last year it's a ransomware
as a service variant
where criminal affiliates conduct
attacks and then share the proceeds with
the ransomware developers
we recommend all critical infrastructure
owners and operators
use the indicators that came out in the
fbi flash
to protect themselves and if other if
other entities are infected
please notify the fbi third the
government is convening stakeholders
more broadly
to ensure everybody has the information
needed to protect themselves
and to rapidly share information this
morning the department of energy
convened calls with the electricity and
oil and gas sectors
to keep them informed the department of
energy
transportation and dhs and others will
be sharing
further indicators of compromise with
the sector information sharing and
analysis centers
or isacs and the department of energy
will be holding additional calls with
critical infrastructure
sector owners as well as state and local
leaders
to ensure everyone has the latest
information about how to protect
themselves
fourth we're taking the threats posed by
ransomware
seriously with several initiatives first
we'll focus on industrial control
systems critical infrastructure as liz
noted in the united states is largely
owned and operated by the private sector
which determines their cyber security
protections are applied to their systems
under that context in mid-april the
administration launched a new
public-private initiative to enhance the
security
of critical infrastructure systems and
improve visibility across
their operational control systems the
systems on which all americans depend
the department of energy had the lead
for the first 100 day sprint
focused on the utility sector and we
will follow with follow-on sprints with
natural gas pipelines
water and other sectors the
administration encourages
all private sector owners of critical
infrastructure to focus on improving
cyber security
and the government remains open and
willing as a partner to support those
efforts
second in tackling ransomware we're
working to disrupt ransomware
infrastructure the fbi recently worked
with international partners to disrupt
two particular strains of ransomware
the immoted and net walker strains more
recently
doj has established a ransomware task
force to ensure
it can better investigate and prosecute
ransomware actors
third cisa is leading a counter
ransomware sprint
which is focused on helping small and
medium-sized companies
who are often the targets of ransomware
better protect
we're themselves greater international
cooperation ransomware affects countries
around the world
to address ransomware because
transnational criminals
are most often the perpetrators of these
crimes and they often leverage global
infrastructure and global
money laundering networks indeed to
combat the exploitation of virtual
currencies
that are often used for payment in
ransomware the us treasury has also been
leading international efforts
including driving development and
adoption of virtual asset standards
under the financial action task force
with those updates
i welcome your questions turning it over
to jen
and liz thank you for your time today
okay honor kick us off
thanks um just uh to clarify something
has colonial paid any ransom and has
there been any advice on that
and then um secondly um
is there any timeline for when americans
should be
certain that this is going to be taken
care of people are getting ready
memorial day is not that far away and
work everyone's concerned about their
gas prices uh what what's the timeline
and
when this thing is going to be under
control absolutely i'll speak to the
first and then i'll turn it to my
colleague liz for the second
so first we recognize that victims of
cyber attacks often face a very
difficult situation
and they have to just balance often the
cost benefit when they have no choice
with regard to paying a ransom
colonial is a private company for
information regarding
their decision on paying a ransom to
them
with the administration offer any advice
on whether or not
to pay around them so typically that is
a private sector decision
and the administration has not offered
further advice at this time
given the rise in ransomware that is one
area we're definitely looking at now to
say what should be
the government's approach to ransomware
actors and to ransoms overall
so on the issue of gas prices as i
indicated right now there are no supply
disruptions and the department of
energy's
information agency the eia is doing the
analysis right now about potential
supply disruptions
and what price effects that could have
and we're working with other agencies to
consider how if necessary we can move
supplies
to a place where it might be needed if
it turns out that there is a shortfall
thank you my question is just a
follow-up
um on what honor was asking has the
white house
broadly considered advice for
companies who are victimized by it
you know in such incidents going forward
is there any advice that you're
considering
uh when it comes to paying ransom in the
future so that's a really good question
the first and most important advice
is secure your systems in this case the
ransomware that was
used is a known variant the fbi has
investigated
many cases of this in the past as i
noted beginning in october
so the first and most important thing is
to ensure that systems are patched
and that cyber security is maintained at
the level needed in a given network
we want to see ransomware not be
successful and that begins with greater
resilience particularly
in critical infrastructure networks and
another question you mentioned uh
perpetrate traders are usually
transnational criminals do you have any
information on whether
this particular incident has any ties to
russia or other
eastern european criminals at this time
we assess that darkseid is a criminal
actor but that's certainly something
that our intelligence community is
looking into joshua can ask a little bit
more about darkseid what what do we know
about them is there any retaliatory
measures that have been taken or are
being considered
by the u.s in response to this or any
investigation that you mentioned that
they've backed off though absolutely so
i mentioned that darkseid is a
ransomware as a service variant it's a
new and very troubling
variant where it's essentially provided
as a service and the proceeds are split
so in that way it's something that we're
particularly troubled by
and i mentioned as well that the fbi has
recently worked with international
partners
to take down and disrupt ransomware
infrastructure we expect that that will
be a continued focus area
to make it far more difficult for these
actors to prey on their victims
even though you're treating it as a
criminal act are you saying it's
state sanctioned or is there a suspicion
that it stayed sanctioned or maybe just
not
don't know where i mentioned a moment
ago currently we assess darkseid as a
criminal actor but of course
our intelligence community is looking
for any ties to any nation-state actors
and if we find that further information
we'll look into it first
first and just to clarify what you said
on ransomware
the fbi has for years advised people not
to pay it
i didn't quite hear you say that so i
wondered whether or not
you're reconsidering the advice the fbi
has given across
many administrations and both you and
liz both mentioned
the concern that the ransomware may have
revealed some kind of data
that would then move over the
operational side or put malware in
that could move to the operational side
we don't have a lot of understanding
about what that concern is
did you know did you see in the in the
early parts of the investigation
that there was malware and the ip side
that could be moved to
operational was it simply that they
froze up their ability
to bill and you know move the
the fuel which has been one theory or
that they simply learned information
that would allow the ransomware
operators to
later on be able to get access to the
main operational site
thank you david so i'll begin and then
of course turn it over to liz if she'd
like to add anything
so first thank you for highlighting the
fbi has provided advice in the past
that paying a ransom would encourage
further ransomware activity and is so
troubling
we recognize though that companies are
often in a difficult position
if their data is encrypted and they do
not have backups and cannot recover the
data
and that is why given the rise in
ransomware and given frankly the
troubling trend we see
of often targeting companies who have
insurance and may be richer targets
that we need to look thoughtfully at
this area including with our
international partners
to determine what we do in addition to
actively disrupting infrastructure and
holding perpetrators accountable
to ensure that we're not encouraging the
rise of ransomware
until your second point regarding the
concerns on the connection between the
information technology and the
operational technology side of a network
the operational technology side of the
network is the part that actually drives
control
of a pipeline for example and as such it
is the more sensitive
part the we are aware that
it is the most significant part colonial
was very careful
and one of the reasons they proactively
chose to shut down the pipeline was
because of concerns to manage the
incident
and gate the ransomware as quickly as
they could
so did you see evidence in the malware
there was something that could move to
the operation
so the colonial incident is the private
sector entity themselves
that being said speaking to the
ransomware directly
the ransomware could of course infect um
technology whether it is on the it side
or for example when there's windows like
technology on the ot side
in this case i won't speak to details
here because it's subject to an
investigation
and those details are are held within
that investigation
but it certainly is a concern we have in
the case of ransomware
and why quickly and effectively gating
the spread of the ransomware is always
the first
area of priority they got to be
quick though go ahead can you explain to
us if you believe
that this uh since it's criminal in your
judgment now that there's a financial
motive there
but do you believe that there was a
desire to try to penetrate
a kind of system that has such huge
implications for
the us economy and so forth and how does
that
create concern for other kinds of
systems the electric grid whatever it
might be other energy companies
or was colonial just a rich target
because they could financially pay
potentially
do you see this as as being about the
infrastructure
more than just the financial incentive
we don't have further information about
the intent
of the perpetrators when conducting the
ransomware hack
against colonial however as you know
ransomware affects broad sectors
and clearly criminals have learned that
those sectors
one of the key sectors we saw during the
covid pandemic was the hospital sector
that was
affected by ransomware clearly we know
we see that criminal actors have focused
on
the more vulnerable victims state and
local governments schools critical
infrastructure and that is why
coming up and addressing ransomware with
great vigor is a key priority of the
administration because we're very
concerned about the growth in ransomware
and the impact it has both on small and
medium businesses as well as the state
and local governments in the united
states
and around the world just two quick ones
do you guys consider
this attack ongoing or has the malicious
actor been removed and then and just to
follow up on something you said that
they have not colonials not yet asked
for cyber support
does that create a problem in terms of
your ability to respond or
the federal government's ability writ
large to get a grasper handle on what's
happening
the details regarding the actual
incident
are being currently investigated by the
fbi
colonial has noted in their public
statement that they've worked to
control the spread of the ransomware and
are actively working to bring back up
their network and they're at the
remediation phase so we are happy to see
the important progress that they made
there
and i'm sorry what was your second
question the company has not yet asked
for cyber support
does that create a problem for your us
government's ability to respond or get a
handle on what's exactly happening when
a private entity is not requesting
support in that capacity
our goal is ensuring that the support is
available so that any private sector
entity who is experiencing a cyber hack
can turn to the government for
remediation assistance and technical
assistance
we judge that the company said that they
have adequate support and they noted in
their public remarks that they're using
a third party service
that they feel they're making adequate
progress with their own resources
and we know we're standing by but that
that is
we're happy that they are confident in
their ability to remediate the incident
and rapidly recover
to meet the needs of their customers um
in this current environment
thank you both so much i'm sorry they
run to another meeting as they go around
the world thank you
for coming thank you okay um i know
we also have a hard stop because of the
president's remarks just keeping you
busy on a monday
uh just a couple of other small things
at the top uh tomorrow president biden
will meet with a bipartisan group of
governors to discuss innovative
innovative ways governors are working to
get
the people in their states vaccinated
the bipartisan group will share with the
president some best practices
on promoting access to vaccination
building confidence in vaccines
and ensuring that everyone is reached in
the vaccination response
he will also acknowledge the
instrumental role democrats republicans
and independents have played in the
vaccination efforts thus far
including helping deliver 220 million
shots
in the first hundred days of his
presidency and he will also discuss how
this continued partnership with
governors is critical to meeting the
goal of achieving
seventy percent of our adult americans
having one shot and 160
million americans fully vaccinated by
july
4th the meeting will include governor
charlie baker of massachusetts utah
governor spencer cox
ohio governor mike dewine new mexico
governor lujan grisham
maine governor janet mills and minnesota
governor tim walls
armor thanks um
is there any reaction um to the
intensifying clashes
um in israel um it's in the last couple
hours this has gone worse i know jake
sullivan was on the phone
over the weekend with his counterpart uh
but it's the president
at this point getting involved is uh
what's the next step forward
and then if i get to say i know we're
tight on time second question
any readout on the uh president's
remarks the bucharest nine
uh sure let me start with the first and
i'll go to the second
uh we are continuing to closely monitor
the violence in israel
uh we have serious concerns about the
situation including violent
confrontations that we've seen over the
last
uh few days as you noted as you noted in
escalation
earlier today uh you also noted armor
that in a call over the weekend
with his israeli counterpart our
national security adviser jake sullivan
reiterated
concerns about the potential evictions
of palestinian families
from their homes and they agreed that
the launching of rocket attacks and
sending incendiary balloons from gaza
towards israel is unacceptable
and must be condemned so this is
something that our national security
team is closely monitoring
obviously across government certainly
the president is kept abreast and is
watching closely as well
and on your second question this meeting
if we haven't put out a readout yet we
will shortly let me give you just a
couple of highlights here that i think i
have available one moment
see here let me um
work to get that to you um shortly after
if i don't have it available here
ah here here we go uh so as almer noted
uh the president spoke today with nato's
eastern flank allies in a virtual summit
uh hosted by uh the president of romania
and poland
he underscored his commitment to
rebuilding alliances and strengthening
transatlantic relationships
he conveyed his desire for closer
cooperation with our nine allies in
central and eastern central europe and
the baltic and black sea regions
on a full range of issues including
global health security
climate change energy security and
global economic recovery
and he also expressed his support for
enhancing nato's deterrence and defense
posture
as well as the importance of allies
increasing their resilience against
harmful economic and political actions
by our strategic competitors in addition
he welcomed the opportunity to engage
with these allies
uh as well as uh nato's the nato
secretary general about alliance efforts
to meet future threats
which will be discussed at the nato
summit in june and finally he stressed
the importance
of strengthening democratic governance
and rule of law at home within the
alliance and around
the world indeed go ahead thank you john
just a quick follow-up um on the
vigorous nine
was the president's decision to
participate in the meeting
uh just sort of was it driven by
this desire to show a united front
against russia
it was a desire to have a partner have a
conversation
and have a discussion with uh some
important partners
in central europe uh in uh in uh
east nato's eastern with east nato's
eastern flank allies about a range of
issues
including security of course in the
region including
uh our efforts to address the global
health crisis
uh climate change energy security this
group was
gathering or they had a pre-pre-set
gathering and they invited him to
address the gathering and
that's exactly what he did thank you go
ahead um
on infrastructure the president spent
the last 10 days
making very clear his view on the merits
of the corporate tax increase
and the white house has rejected user
fees as paid for yeah
the republicans have made clear the 2017
tax law is a non-starter and are
proposing user fees to pay for it
i don't understand what the deal space
is here when
their pay fors are considered
non-starters by you guys and your pay
forwards are considered not starters by
theirs
well this is a big week ahead phil uh so
big week for someone who covered capitol
hill and is now covering
the white house uh look i think the
president
the president's red lines are in action
and are anything that would raise taxes
on people making less than 400
000 a year uh those are not areas where
he is going to move
uh he is quite open uh as is evidenced
by the fact that he invited
uh senator capito and a group of members
to meet with him in the white house
later this week he's very open to having
a discussion about
uh where we can find agreement where we
can
move forward and he has been encouraged
by the spirit in which senator capito
and other republican colleagues are
engaging with him
and he's hopeful that the meeting will
be constructive now you're right and
what you touched on which is an
interesting piece of this is that
the disagreement is really about the pay
force uh there is agreement about the
need to modernize our infrastructure
about the need to
do more to create jobs in the economy
um and he's looking forward to hearing
what additional ideas they may have
one more quick one um i understand where
you guys and the fed are
that inflation right now is transitory
if it pops
yeah to the degree that it does the jobs
report kind of was a reminder that we
don't necessarily
have a road map for coming out of a once
in a century pandemic economically
are you guys concerned about what would
happen if you were wrong and it's not
transitory and this ends up being an
actual real problem in the weeks or
months ahead what comes to inflation
well let me first say that our economic
team watches this incredibly closely
including our secretary of treasury who
uh has an expansive background in
watching uh
inflation uh and so we have confidence
in both
their assessments to date and also the
fact that they will watch this
as we continue to assess the state of
our economy
i will say that and the president will
talk about this uh
shortly i should say uh later this
afternoon
uh that his view is that um you know
we need to we we've always believed that
this would be there would be ups and
downs
in our uh jobs reports that is
historically how it has gone
uh that there are a number of factors
that contribute to
uh it being a challenge for people to uh
hire and people to rejoin the workforce
and there are steps we can take and this
is what he will talk about in his
remarks
as a government we've obviously taken a
number of those steps including
passing the american rescue plan but
there are a number of barriers to work
the biggest barriers we've seen
affordability of child care
schools reopening vaccinations is
actually a huge factor so
when you dig into this data which
obviously we've done over the last
couple of days
one interesting thing that struck the
president is interesting is that
uh the week of april 12 which is the
week that the data was compiled for the
april jobs report was collected
at that point only 18 of 18 to 64 year
olds
were fully vaccinated and as of may 9th
it's risen to 34
the seven day moving average of positive
cova cases was 40 percent higher in mid
april
than may 8 last week when the data was
compiled for next month
so all i'm conveying is there are a
range of factors he'll talk about
our announcements on state and local
funding how that will be distributed
which will help keep police firefighters
and others on the job
he'll talk about delivering assistance
to restaurants which is some where we
see
major opportunity for employment or
rehiring
he'll talk about providing guidance to
child care centers which will help
ensure that that funding gets out the
door to cover child costs he'll talk
about the
employee retention tax tax credit which
will hopefully help small
and medium-sized businesses but he also
believes that there are steps businesses
need to take which we'll also talk about
employers can get people vaccinated
they can pay people a decent wage these
larger companies have received 1.4
trillion dollars in
money they can do a better job of paying
a decent wage to bring people back into
the
workforce and so you know there's a lot
of steps uh
different entities can take and that's
where he think where he'll
discuss this afternoon and where he
thinks the focus should be go ahead
thank you two topics really quick first
on ethics waivers the white house
apparently had
ethics restrictions that were preventing
officials who work here from
communicating with the unions
they worked at previously and they
waived them for
somebody at omb and somebody made an
america office uh and i'm curious why
that happened well first since you gave
me an opportunity i will reiterate
that this administration has the
president signed an executive order
requiring all appointees across the
federal government
to sign the most stringent ethics code
ever adopted by any white house
so as you referred to in the narrow
circumstances when necessary and in the
public's interest
the order authorizes agencies to grant
limited waivers and consultation
with white house counsel's office
including in the cases
your sighting president of course has
stood strong for unions throughout his
career and he's proud to have leading
labor voices in the white house and
there are circumstances
very very limited where it is in the
interests of
uh governing in the interest of getting
work done for the american people to
issue these waivers
and then on the economy so employment
only rose by
about 266 000 jobs in april out of 7.4
million
or so job openings how does the white
house know that people are just choosing
not to
apply for jobs because the extra
unemployment benefits are so good
well first let me say that we have
looked at the data and
secretary yellen referred to this on
friday or talked about this on friday
we don't see much evidence that the
extra unemployment
insurance is a major driver in
people not rejoining the workforce we
actually see the data
and our analysis shows that
lack of vaccination the lower rate which
is why i refer to the data and the week
that it was taken
it has an impact child care has an
impact schools reopening has an impact
but there is also the need to pay a
livable working
wage and that's one of the reasons the
president will talk about that this
afternoon
as bank of america economists who are
cited in a bloomberg story say anybody
making less than 32 thousand dollars a
year is better off
financially just taking the unemployment
benefits so is the white house creating
an incentive just to stay home well
again uh
the majority of economists internally
and
externally of the white house don't feel
that unemployment insurance something
that was
done um at a time where to help
unemployed people
get through a very difficult economic
downturn during a pandemic
is a dr is the a major driver in uh in
our unemployment data that there are
other factors bigger factors
that were contributing have been
contributing to the numbers we saw on
friday
that's what we're working to address uh
and
that's where we think our solution
should be focused just last one really
quick
the commerce secretary says the main
reason that people are staying home is
fear how does the white house know that
people are scared what is that based on
well i think what she was referring to
is the fact that there were
there was a much lower vaccination rate
just a month ago
and that people are fearful about
getting sick
they are fearful about whether they're
going to have the conditions to be
healthy whether they
can send their kids to a child care
center whether there is a child care
center
so those are all factors that are
consistent with uh
the examples and reasons i just provided
go ahead josh
you mentioned if you're monitoring
inflation and that with the jobs report
you expected sort of you know lumpy
reports from month to month
do you expect the same thing with the
inflation report is the white house
bracing
for kind of an eye-popping top-line
number given the base effects it will be
going off of
or are you not sort of cautioning that i
worry people will overreact to the one
number that will come up
well uh obviously our analysis is going
to be done by our economic experts
they continue to convey that they
believe the impact will be
temporary transitory however you want to
refer to it but they're looking at it
closely but i don't have any projections
on that to make from here today can i
ask a little bit more about vaccinations
the average has dropped from about three
point four million four weeks
about two million it looks like it's a
little off there they're declining
steadily
is that where you expect it to continue
to decide to keep
coming down and what are the factors
that you think are driving that pretty
substantial drop over the past
month or so sure well we always expected
we'd be in a different phase
and we were at a phase just a several
weeks ago and you cover this closely so
you know well
where there was such a demand for the
vaccine
people were eager to get their
appointment they were
had vaccine t-shirts they were doing
selfies we are now at the point which we
always knew we would be at
where the supply has uh increased
has has exceeded the demand and it means
we have to
work extra hard to get into communities
to have partnerships with us
with local doctors with of primary care
physicians to expand
access expand mobile units that are
going into communities to get the supply
out to people
we have reached uh hit a a higher number
than i think most people anticipated
at this point um since the president was
inaugurated the number of people who
have been vaccinated who've received
their first dose and are
hopefully on their way to their second
dose so we knew we'd be in this phase
and we knew we'd be in a phase where
it'd be more difficult
because we need to increase access which
we've been focused on doing from the
beginning
and continue to increase confidence
we've seen progress in both areas
two weeks ago the 10 million doses of
astrosenica that were being reviewed do
you have an update on that at all are
they still
reviewing it they are still reviewing it
uh we don't have an update quite yet
um and we're working uh to hopefully
have more for you on what our uh how our
approach and what our assessment will be
of how those doses will be distributed
thanksgiving
that i don't have anything to preview on
that at this point in time go ahead
david
back to this interesting question on the
unemployment benefits
one suggestion the republicans have been
making is end those benefits
earlier than the current plan which i
think is the end of september
and use that money to go into
infrastructure
is that being taken up uh by your side
i'm certain they will bring many ideas
to the meeting uh
meetings later this week that may be one
of them but again i think it's important
to note that
we don't see the unemployment benefits
as a major
driver in the jobs numbers
we see there being a number of other
factors that have a larger impact
including uh the pace of vaccination
just a month ago
the child care impacts the need to get
more money out into state and local
communities
so that's where our focus is going to be
and for us it's important that we
continue to remain
uh solutions oriented on uh areas where
we feel can be most beneficial to the
economy and not
uh be moved by talking points
go ahead yeah thanks john uh the white
house sent out earlier that uh the
president's meeting later today with
senator carper and senator manchin i was
wondering
if you could just uh give us a preview
of what they plan to discuss
and why those two senators in particular
were invited or looking virtual i don't
know
sure well i would expect um the
president will have you already know he
has a number of meetings scheduled this
week
one with a bike bipartisan bicameral
leadership meeting on wednesday
he also has the meeting with senator
capito and a group of republican
senators on thursday so
these are just examples of two senators
uh additional
members he'll be meeting with to discuss
the american jobs plan discuss the path
forward and
i'm not sure we'll have a big readout
afterwards but it's just a part of his
ongoing outreach
and given just really you said you know
what a big week it is he has so many
meetings and so many lawmakers is this
sort of
uh i guess like a defining week would
you say for for how things are going to
proceed
on uh the jobs plan the family's plan um
is the white house sort of you know
setting any kind of deadline you've
mentioned memorial day it's a time to
see progress
i'm curious you know where you kind of
go after this week given all the
meetings that are
still here the president would still
like to see progress by memorial day
um and would like to sign uh the bills
into law this summer that hasn't changed
but we don't have a new deadline but of
course a number of meetings and
the senate's back and there'll be all
sorts of conversations happening this
week
sorry kelly go ahead do you have a sense
that as the president tonight his first
meeting with kevin mccarthy here
at uh that leadership meeting you talked
about
obviously the house republicans have
some of their own internal
matters going on does the president
think any discord they are having
has an influence or comes into the
meetings that he will have with
leadership does that affect how he views
sitting down with them at all no the
president knows
that there is some
introspection going on in the republican
party right now and
a determination about who they're going
to be who they want to lead them and
what they want to represent moving
forward
he's not going to focus on that he also
believes that
the american people did not elect him to
accept improbability or impossibility of
working in a bipartisan manner
so the role he can play as president of
the united states is to
continue to seek ways to work together
and the fact is we are continuing to
work even with
the um family excitement that's
happening on the other side of the aisle
um we are continuing to work with
republicans on a range of issues
national security we we passed our we
we confirmed our uh our uh cabinet uh in
a
a faster pace since then since reagan uh
we're working to
increase our competition uh there are a
lot of ways we're working with
republicans
even as uh they're determining who they
are moving forward
go in the back thank you again both
german chancellor merkel and french
president marquette expressed their
concerns over u.s policy towards vaccine
basically been underlying the need for
more exports beat for the vaccine itself
or the components
does the president understand their
frustration and more broadly
do you think he underestimated the
negative reactions around the world
well let me first say that the
president's commitment to a global covet
19 response
has been steadfast and consistent since
day one when we made the decision to
rejoin the who we understand that
the border the virus knows no borders
that it is important for the united
states
to continue to play a central role in
addressing
the global pandemic we've invested more
than any other country in kovacs
and we're pushing other countries to
invest more in the program to get
vaccines to developing countries
we're working to boost global production
through partnerships like the quad
partnership moderna and pfizer have
announced plans and intentions to
increase supply and get it out to the
global community and of course we've
announced that we are going to
uh share 60 million doses 10 million of
which as josh
referred to or alluded to earlier will
be hopefully approved by the fda
soon so there's no question we're
playing a role we will continue to play
an increased role
uh in efforts to address the pandemic
and get the pandemic under control
go ahead in the back thank you john
speaking of
uh nato's eastern flank uh
the important part of uh security system
in the central and eastern europe was
supposed to be u.s missile defense site
in poland
the project stalled during the previous
administration it
has been delayed twice is president by
then committed
to completing the the project
i don't have anything to preview about a
bilateral project or project in poland
at this point in time the president
addressed this group today
he provided remarks obviously a group of
nine
countries uh so it was not focused on
one particular country even though i
know the president of poland was a
co-host
of the event um i can certainly follow
up with our national security team and
see if there's more to report
go ahead we're seeing president uh as a
tendency in some areas to resume
activities that even the cbc says are
safe you know wearing uh not wearing a
mask outside if you're fully vaccinated
or even
in particular in person schooling does
the administration have a strategy
on helping cure those anxieties around
the country and
make sure that the reopening can go
smoothly as possible
the reopening of schools well we
actually saw data that came out just
last week that showed more than 50
percent of schools are open five days a
week
and that data is from march so we're
actually seeing increasing numbers as
schools
uh receive the american rescue plan
funding and as they apply the mitigation
uh measures uh so i'm not sure but was
there specific data you were referring
to
or reopening schools but getting
families confident that sending their
children to those schools
are safe sure uh this is uh certainly as
we look
to uh uh wait for and hope for of course
uh approval of uh the uh of one of the
vaccines to
to be safe for 12 to 15 year olds i know
this is something that's on the minds of
uh parents around the country my kids
are not quite that old but i certainly
relate to and understand that
and we will continue to do what we have
done with a range of communities
across the country where there has been
uh issues with confidence whether it's
communities of color
where there has been a massive increase
in confidence as more people get
vaccinated
or more conservative communities where
we've also seen an increase in
confidence as more people in communities
are vaccinated
so one of the reasons that we are
partnering with
with primary care physicians and local
doctors is because we know that is an
effective way
not just with adults but with parents to
help address questions they have
concerns they have about whether or not
getting the vaccine taking the vaccine
for their kids is safe is effective
and is necessary and that is a program
we will continue to increase our
investment in i think we'll have more to
say about that in the coming days
sorry i was trying to understand your
question go ahead thanks um
to go back to the colonial pipeline if
the u.s
does begin to see a shortage of supply
would they consider would you consider
waving the jones act
so as uh as dr sherwood randall alluded
to we have an interagency process that
was stood up this weekend and is meeting
uh regularly
many times a day about a range of
options i'm not going to get ahead of
those options and at this point in time
i would just reiterate we don't see a
supply issue
go in the back thanks for taking my
question
the first is is there does the president
have a sense of how many democrats
are fully on board with the 4 trillion
dollars worth of plans right now
given that he's meeting with these two
democratic senators and is there any
readjustment happening
with the jobs plan or the families plan
this because of the disappointing
jobs report last week well i would first
say that um
the president has been regularly
discussing with not just speaker pelosi
and senator schumer but
a range of members i should say also
senior members of the white house team
have primarily been playing this role
have had dozens and dozens of meetings
and engagements and discussions about
these proposals and what's important to
a variety of members as you know yamiche
you know there are some members we've
been talking about a lot who want to see
a smaller package some want to see a
larger package
so there's a range of points of view
that will certainly continue to be a
part of the discussion
this meeting with bipartisan leaders on
wednesday
of course the jobs plan will be a part
of it they'll also discuss a range of
issues and a range of items on the
agenda during that meeting but i don't
the discussions are ongoing and there
are a range of viewpoints that we're in
taking on we're answering questions and
that
is not just certainly not just with
republicans it's with a range of
democrats as well
the question was basically how many
democrats and does the president have a
sense that he can pass the
at least with democrat support right now
well
again yamiche what i was conveying is
that there are a range of democrats and
republicans who have different ideas
about
what the priorities are what they should
be some may even want different
components of the package to be bigger
some may want it to be smaller so all of
that is being assessed as we have a
discussion there isn't a bill that's
going to the floor next week
we're in the early sausage making stage
of the discussion with
members of both parties the first is
just on policing
does the president would the president
sign a bill that didn't include an end
to qualified immunity when it came to
policing
jim clyburn is supporting that now
what's the president's stance
on qualifying the the president is uh
eager to see what the outcome of
negotiations are and he
certainly trusts in the leadership of uh
congresswoman bass senator booker
uh but his focus is on uh his hope that
he can sign
the george floyd justice and policing
act into law on may
25th if i'm getting the date correct uh
and he will not we're not going to get
ahead of those negotiations
he doesn't have a stance right now that
he would that he would say we're not
gonna we're not gonna take a stance in
the middle of the
i have is negotiations schooling i saw
some numbers that said
black children of or half of them have
gone back to school
about two-thirds of asian-american
children have enrolled in remote school
compared to about 20 of white students
essentially the point is that black
latino and asian students aren't going
back to school at the same rates as
white students or a lot of people who
are worried about their equity gap
does the administration have a goal and
a number in mind for
for how this should be um playing out
when it comes to
students and who's going back to school
and what what are the aim what's the aim
there
yeah well one of the challenges is that
the data is from march
and so the data at this point is a month
and a half
old it still shows encouraging signs but
as you pointed out there yamiche
it's not nearly where we want it to be
at the end
you know at the conclusion of this and
the focus of secretary cardona
and on our department of education is
ensuring we're getting these funds out
to the communities that need it
in order to reopen reopen as quickly as
possible five days a week
there are also entities that i think one
of your colleagues over here asked about
in terms of
concerns about the vaccine and safety
and advocacy that we need to
continue to address at the same time as
well so we will continue to dig into the
data one of the things secretary cardone
has been focusing on focused on
is connecting schools and best practices
uh so that they can learn is it a
funding issue
is it uh you know addressing other
challenges issue and
that school districts and schools can
learn from each other but our goal and
objective
is to have all schools open five days a
week
uh and that's what we're working toward
and we're not going to be satisfied
until we get there
i know that i think you have to gather
or maybe we're even late for that so i'm
going to wrap this
up but we'll see you again tomorrow
thanks everyone
you